>> FOR DECADES, AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS HAVE BEEN WRONGFULLY
FORCED TO SUBSIDIZE THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY THROUGH TITLE X FEDERAL
FUNDING.
SO TODAY WE HAVE KEPT ANOTHER
PROMISE.
MY ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED A
NEW RULE TO PROHIBIT TITLE X
FUNDING FROM GOING TO ANY CLINIC
THAT PERFORMS ABORTIONS.
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WITHIN THEIR
POWER TO BLOCK IT.
ON THIS ISSUE, LIKE SO MANY
OTHER ISSUES, THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS FAR OUTSIDE THE
AMERICAN MAINSTREAM.
>> Laura: THAT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVERING THE
KEYNOTE ADDRESS TONIGHT AT THE
SUSAN B. ANTHONY ANNUAL CAMPAIGN
FOR LIFE GALA.
A PART OF THE PRESIDENT'S
STRATEGY IS TO RALLY THE BASE AS
WE HEAD INTO THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND HIS FOCUS ON
PRO-LIFE INITIATIVES THERE.
HERE TO DISCUSS THAT AND SO MUCH
MORE, ONE OF THE PRESIDENT'S TOP
ADVISORS, KELLYANNE CONWAY WHO
HERSELF TONIGHT RECEIVED A BIG
AWARD FROM THE SUSAN B. ANTHONY
LIST.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT
PRAISED YOU.
WE WERE WATCHING IN THE BACK AND
THIS WAS A FUN MOMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> SHE IS SOME FIGHTER.
SHE WILL DO THE SHOWS THAT
NOBODY ELSE DARES GO NEAR.
I WILL SAY TO THIS ONE OR THAT
ONE.
NO PROBLEM, SIR.
>> Laura: I SAID TO WOMEN,
WAIT A MINUTE, KELLY IS COMING
ON OUR SHOW.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT HE MEANS.
>> Laura: WE WERE WATCHING,
HE'S THE MOST I THINK PRO-LIFE
PRESIDENT WE'VE EVER HAD AND
DEFENDING LIFE, THE MOST
INNOCENT AMONG US WHO HAVE NO
LOBBYISTS AND NO FAT CATS BEHIND
THEM AND IT'S NOT HIS CROWD,
IT'S A MANHATTAN CROWD.
I'M SORRY, BUT I WAS SO MOVED BY
THAT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION, TONIGHT
IN MY REMARKS I TOOK OUT THE
LETTER FROM SEPTEMBER 2015 THAT
CANADA TRUMP SIGNED.
WANTED HIM TO SIGN THIS LETTER
TO ACTIVATE THE GRASSROOTS.
HE SAID WE NEED SOME PROMISES,
SOME COMMITMENTS FROM THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE.
HE LOOKED AT THE LETTER AND
TALKED ABOUT PARTIAL-BIRTH
ABORTION.
SIGNING CAPABLE UNBORN.
CERTAINLY MOVING, AS SUGGESTED
TONIGHT, THE FUNDING FROM
CLINICS THAT PROVIDE ABORTIONS
TO THOSE THAT PROVIDE TRUE
WOMEN'S HEALTH SERVICES LIKE
MAMMOGRAMS AND SCREENINGS AND
OTHER SERVICES.
HE LOOKED AT IT AND HE SAID
THAT'S ALL FINE, BUT WHERE IS
ALL THAT STUFF ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON, AND HE ADDED
STUFF ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A COPY
OF THE LETTER AND HE SIGNED IT
AND IT WENT ON AND ON ABOUT HOW
EXTREME SHE IS, THAT SHE WOULD
TAKE THE BABY OUT OF ITS
MOTHER'S WOMB.
HE FOLLOWED IT UP ON
OCTOBER 19TH AND GAVE THE MOST
IMPASSIONED DEFENSE EVER HEARD
FROM A PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE
GOING.
LET'S REMIND EVERYBODY THIS IS A
MANHATTAN MALE BILLIONAIRE WHO
FOR MOST OF HIS ADULT LIFE HAS
SAID HE WAS PRO-CHOICE.
>> Laura: HE DOESN'T REALLY
MEAN IT.
>> LOOK AT HIS RECORD.
MEXICO CITY POLICY.
FIRST PRESIDENT EVER TO ADDRESS
THIS GALA.
THE MARCH FOR LIFE AND
MIKE PENCE OF COURSE IS HIS
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT TO DO THE
SAME THING.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE POLICIES AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL PROBABLY SAY THIS IS JUST A
GOOD START.
>> Laura: THE ISSUE OF CHINA
IS BIG NOW BECAUSE SO MANY OF US
SUPPORT OF THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
OF HIS TOUGH LINE ON CHINA.
THE CHINA 2025 PLAN SEEKING TO
DOMINATE EVERY MAJOR INDUSTRY,
STOLEN OR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN FANTASTIC
ON THIS ISSUE BUT THIS IS WHAT
CHUCK SCHUMER SAYS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I AM REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S HEMMING AND
HAWING OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS
WHEN IT COMES TO CHINA.
YOU COULD SAY THAT PRESIDENT XI
IS WRITING THE ART OF THE DEAL,
NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
UNFORTUNATELY EVERY TIME
PRESIDENT XI FLATTERS OUR
PRESIDENT HE SEEMS TO BACK OFF A
TOUGH DEAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE TOUGH ON CHINA.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE YOUR ACTIONS
MATCH OUR RHETORIC.
>> Laura: IN MY MIND THE WORST
THING THAT COULD HAPPEN IS THE
DEMOCRATS OUT-POPULIST THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS ISSUE.
THAT WOULD BE A GIFT.
CAN YOU REASSURE VIEWERS DENY
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
RETAIN HIS STRENGTH AND APPROACH
TO CHINA GOT HIM ELECTED?
>> THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THIS
TODAY AND THE OVERALL PLACE
WHILE THE CAMERA WAS ROLLING.
HE WAS MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT MOON OF SOUTH KOREA
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR
FROM THE BEGINNING HE THINKS
THAT THE IMBALANCE, UNFAIR
NUMBER
NONRECIPROCAL TRADE DEALS ARE
KILLING THE AMERICAN WORKER AND
HE WILL ALWAYS FIGHT FOR THEM
FIRST.
HE TALKS ABOUT THE $500 BILLION
TRADE DEFICIT WE HAVE WITH
CHINA.
AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE HAPPY
THAT AT SOME OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS IN BEIJING AND HERE
LAST WEEK AT THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT CHINA SIGNALS A MOVE TO BUY
MORE AGRICULTURE, BUY MORE
ENERGY FOR EXAMPLE.
BUT THE PRESIDENT ALSO, IF HE
THINKS THE DEAL IS NOT GOOD FOR
AMERICANS, HE'S HAPPY TO WALK
AWAY FROM IT.
HE'S BEEN DOING THAT HIS ENTIRE
CAREER.
CONCERNED THAT YOU HEAR MARCO
RUBIO, SCHUMER, THEY SEE AN
OPENING HERE.
TRUMP DOMINATED THAT SPACE IN
2016.
NO ONE HAD DONE IT LIKE HE HAD
DONE IT.
NOW THEY SEE SOUR GUM AND
SOYBEANS ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
OUR ENTIRE TECH SECTOR THAT HAS
GOTTEN RIPPED OFF AS THEY
CONTINUE TO STEAL OUR IP.
AND THEY ARE PLAYING LONG BALL
HERE.
THEY ARE NOT PLAYING SHORT BALL.
THEY ARE PLAYING LONG BALL FOR
TOTAL DOMINATION.
>> TALKING ABOUT TECHNOLOGY
TRANSFERS.
U.S. TRADE REPRESENTATIVES WENT
OVER TO BEIJING, TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THEY ARE STEALING OUR
INNOVATION, STEALING OUR FUTURE
FRANKLY.
>> Laura: DIFFERENT SIDES ON
THIS, IS THERE A REAL WAR GOING
ON INSIDE?
>> NO, I THINK PEOPLE LIKE TO
COVER PALACE INTRIGUE INSTEAD OF
LEARNING THE POLICIES.
>> Laura: HUGE DIVIDE IN THE
PARTY ENTREE.
>> HE CAME OUT, I THINK ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
ELEVATE, TWO OF THE ISSUES THAT
DONALD WAS TO ELEVATE AS A
CANDIDATE FOR MIRED IN LOW
SINGLE DIGITS TO PUTTING OUT
THERE ON THE PLATFORM WAS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND TRADE.
LITTLE SINGLE DIGITS ALL THE WAY
OUT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT FAIRNESS TO HIM.
IT'S FAIRNESS TO AMERICANS.
>> Laura: NORTH KOREA,
SHIFTING, MOVING, CAN YOU TELL
US ANYTHING NEW ON THAT?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT TONIGHT ASKING THE
PRESS TO SIGN UP IF THEY ARE
GOING TO COVER THE SUMMIT IN
SINGAPORE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO COVER IT.
>> WE ARE STILL PLANNING ON JUL
>> WE ARE STILL PLANNING ON JUL2
>> WE ARE STILL PLANNING ON JULH
>> WE ARE STILL PLANNING ON JUL.
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT VERY CLEAR
FROM THE BEGINNING AND SET IT
AGAIN TODAY THAT IF IT HAPPENS
THAT'S GREAT, IF IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN THAT'S OKAY TOO.
WE ARE STILL WAY AHEAD.
IT WAS STILL MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS THERE BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP.
WITHOUT HIM NORTH KOREA WOULD
NOT BE TALKING TO SOUTH KOREA.
THOSE THREE AMERICAN DETAINEES
WOULD NOT BE BACK.
>> Laura: HE WAS HINTING THAT
PRESIDENT XI WAS PART OF IT.
>> HE SAID I THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS A WORLD CLASS POKER PLAYER.
SO WHAT WE ARE LOOKING -- WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID IS THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS, CONTINUE TO TALK.
BUT THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO HAVE
A SUMMIT.
THE GOAL IS DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA AND THAT'S
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AT
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING A
AT.
>> Laura: JOHN BOLTON IS GOING
TO BE GOING ON THE TRIP?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE.
>> Laura: I SHOULD HOPE SO.
THEY DON'T WANT IN THERE BUT I
HOPE HE DOES.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE AWARD.